this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history on this
episode Jonathan is taking another look
at the wild west Weaponry of hunt
Showdown and he even had a few requests
from The Game's developers themselves my
name is Vinnie and I'm senior animator
for Han Showdown I would like to see uh
the Sparks pistol and the Romero Alamo
being analyzed now did anyone do this to
a shop historically I kind of hope not
it would work there's no there's no
mechanism or anything up here that we
would interfere with especially within
the context of this game absolutely see
why why that would make some sense you
could make yourself quite a potent
little hand Cannon if there are any
other games guns and mechanics that you
guys want to see Jonathan break down let
us know in the comment section below and
if you'd like to help out the Royal
armies Museum and continue to support
Jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right over
to Jonathan
foreign
late 19th century setting if I remember
rightly for for this game so the 1890
Bertier Cavalry carbine which is what
this is is absolutely fine for that uh
the only thing I'd say about that is
that this are pretty as we say in the UK
knackered they look really old the
woodwork's worn and cracked the wood
these metal work looks very worn and
depending what the year is you know this
thing's introduced in France as the
latest Cavalry arm in 1890 is there
really time for this to have ended up on
the other side of the pond and be this
worn out probably not but another case
of me overthinking the situation
foreign
this thing looks like the Colt
1871-2 open top revolver design the
barrel assembly with the ejector housing
on it and the profile of that's quite
distinctive the the hammer is curious
looking like it's made out of brass or
what used to be called gun metal yeah
weird so it's got It's got a brass
Hammer with a added on steel firing pin
pinned to the end of that hammer doesn't
make a huge amount of sense but that's
what I see but this thing looks great in
first person really detailed nicely
modeled the sort of decorative features
stand out really nicely but also the the
condition of the thing so we've got that
ejector rod assembly on the side of the
barrel this is what gives the Single
Action Army its distinctive appearance
it would look very weird if it didn't
have it uh point of that is clearly to
enable you to eject empty cases because
when cartridge cases are fired they
expand yes they do retract slightly but
they don't by any means fully contract
sorry not retract so they are they do
ask they are a little bit stuck in there
by friction and also by a bit of fouling
that's been blown back around the mouth
of the case but mainly that sort of
stiction from from the metal and so you
cannot just
shake the Garden or would you wish to
try shaking the gun to just let the
empty case fall out
all right another very recognizable
historic firearm so the Browning Auto
five this is one of ours it happens to
have a military style sling on it and a
rib on the barrel and we've got you know
a really nicely done copy of the
Browning here with maybe a couple of
Minor Details that are different or at
least different from the version that I
have in front of me and uh some some
decoration but plausible shotgun style
decoration that we just don't have on
this example the name is a bit weird
crownland King I don't think that's a
reference to anything from the real gun
and I see that they've spotted this bit
of real estate on the on the back of the
receiver it's characteristic humped
receiver and they've put a maker's mark
on there now I don't think I've ever
seen an auto 5 with anything marked
there if you have let us know it does
seem like an obvious place to put
markings but they haven't put it on this
one
all right so at first I thought we were
looking at a bit of a cheeky plus one
here where we would just insert five
rounds into what is supposed to be a
four round tube but actually the way
it's the way it works is you insert as
many as you can but you then [ __ ] the
gun freeing up a space in the magazine
of course for then a Top-Up but yeah
this is a perfectly valid way of doing
it of course doable on any for on almost
any firearm so something I do like to
see and would like to see more of is
firearms and games that you can interact
with as though they're real if that
makes sense so it's not just not just
going through the motions of an
animation when you press a button you
are pressing a button to operate that
feature on the gun
[Applause]
it's my old friend the so-called broom
handle Mauser the c96
we have one here in its holster slash
butt stock that you've seen before this
is of the right sort of generation it
matched a really quite a close match for
the one on screen doesn't the hammer
isn't quite right for this model for
this commercial model of the c96 but
it's really very good otherwise all the
necessary Contours and cut out panels
and things are there I'd have to be
incredibly nitpicky to spot anything
wrong with that they've done a good job
foreign
[Applause]
as nice as the feature is that shows
this thing in operation it does reveal a
flaw with the animation so yes the bolt
does
operate in the way shown to some extent
so it does move back and forth like this
cocking the hammer extracting and
ejecting cases chambering the next round
from the fixed magazine however that's
not how the Gun Works it's still the
bolt still has to be unlocked just like
on a slide operated gun and to do that
the whole upper part of the gun has to
move just that short distance there
before the
um locking locking piece on the bottom
of the on the bottom of this assembly
drops down the lugs go out of Engagement
and the bolt can then you can see how
easily I'm pulling that back just with
finger and thumb
that's because that's unlocked
when it's forward way more pressure
required for me to pull back on that and
I can't help but end up locking it open
because we don't have any rounds in the
magazine quite nerdy but um if you want
to show this thing operating like you
wouldn't you know we wouldn't um we'd
always comment on a slide on a gun not
moving aside on a pistol not moving a
normal self-loading pistol same applies
here it's just that it's the whole upper
part of the gun that moves
[Music]
like that
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh that's superb yeah we often scratch
our heads at uh how how games fudge
reloads where usually for Jewel wielding
so usually off camera or kind of like
fudged to put put the two two broom
handles together insert the clips and
then smack them into each other to load
it that's borderline genius is what that
is and I'm not gonna do it but I
actually think it would work
hi Dave again just interrupting to
provide a little background for this
next clip basically last time Jonathan
saw hunt Showdown back in March 2021 he
critiqued the Sparks rifle of having a
redundant cocking animation in its
reload crytek actually saw the episode
and well they implemented Jonathan's
feedback and changed the animation
wow well that's that's um oddly humbling
to see developers taking on board my um
my sorted Rambles on video game Firearms
pleasing but but also humbling thank you
very much for for taking that on board
it's looking great I've just I've
grabbed the sharps or Sparks as the game
calls it and uh yeah it's half [ __ ] open
it cartridge in close it full [ __ ]
fire it works exactly as advertised how
long Showdown and I would like to see uh
the Sparks pistol and the Romero Alamo
being analyzed
what have they done to you
poor poor thing now did anyone do this
to a shop historically I kind of hope
not but uh yeah so if you I mean it
would work there's no there's no
mechanism or anything up here that we
would interfere with by cutting the poor
Barrel off hacking away at the at the
stock some nice detail there the damaged
wood where it's been roughly hewn
especially within the context of this
game absolutely see why why that would
make some sense you could make yourself
quite a potent little hand Cannon by
doing this
foreign
that is really cool to see my friends
and colleagues at Sea and Arsenal a
couple of years ago now had a video on
the alofts magazine system for single
barrel shotguns and that's what we see
here I'm not even gonna nitpick the
exact uh details of it I'm just super
impressed that the guys knew about this
and that they have put it in the game
because it is incredibly cool definitely
go over to Sea and Arsenal and watch
that video on the alofts if anyone's
come across the harston quick loader for
the martini Henry which is almost
equally as obscure but we we had a video
on it on the Royal armories Channel
while I'm plugging everyone Under the
Sun uh similar idea trying to strap a
magazine onto a weapon that was never
designed to have a magazine and it works
as you see here hi I'm Alex Medina I'm a
senior heart service artist at crytek
and I would like to see the Schofield
revolver analyzed
okay I have I have to pause this video
Bang on a discharge and it might be
happening a bit far back in the in the
sort of recoil cycle if that makes sense
but we've got a very nice depiction of
the silent of The Flash in the cylinder
Gap where you get a flash in a bit of
smoke between the cylinder and the
barrel the timing might be a little bit
off there because that would happen on
discharge and then the recoil happens
immediately after that but that would be
incredibly nitpicky of me so it is like
a a snub nose Scofield the Scofield
should have a longer Barrel than that
but that kind of is a kind of
overshadowed by the huge knuckle duster
which does I do I like the look of this
thing quite a bit
foreign
Winchester 1887 shotgun we have a
somewhat truncated one here
um you might have seen before in my
hands still has the butt stock on it
game clearly gives you different options
in that regard some of these guns are so
nicely modeled I think it's a shame that
they have rust on them I'm kind of
hoping there's a mechanic for cleaning
them or at least finding pristine or
more pristine versions but it definitely
adds character and fits the sort of
cowboy diesel Grime of the whole feel of
this uh operates pretty pretty well
correctly not pretty correctly correctly
um we can actually see the thumb
reaching down to insert rounds into the
magazine tube we've got the spin cocking
thing now you do need the large loop for
that or you're going to break your break
your hand but then also the conventional
reload as well um I think a game like
this might even be incomplete without a
Winchester 1887 to be fair
foreign
another must-have in a an old west set
game is of course the Winchester it's
looking good although the scoped version
we've got the empty cases clipping
through the scope tube and in fact even
if they weren't it wouldn't be a great
setup because you'd have a chance of
something that happened with the early
sa80 automatic rifles in the UK was that
you could actually have cases bounce
back into the action and and create a
stoppage which is I suppose you'd have a
percentage chance of that happening if
it hit dead on the bottom of this of the
scope tube it could very well end up
causing a like a stovepipe type Jam
which is unusual in a lever action but
could actually happen so when you see
scoped Winchester's have a think about
how high the scope is mounted whether
it's offset scoping Winchester's wasn't
wasn't incredibly common to be fair
oh I'll stop you there
right that's a that's a new one I mean
the rifle's not new on me um we have a
number of them uh it's the French
LaBelle standard service rifle of the
first world war and it's it's nicely
represented on the screen in front of me
except for but it's still nice it's just
not realistic so the buck plate has been
replaced by I think it's meant to be
like a butt plate and then like a meat
cleaver now of course having a really
sharp well I don't know how sharp it is
but a very sharp and potentially Rusty
bit of metal directly under where your
hand is going to be yeah don't don't
fancy that but I kind of look I'm kind
of looking forward to seeing this in use
I think it's going to be just a guess a
sort of butt stroke
a fair rather than spin it round and use
it like a polax or something but I'm
excited to find out
yep it's the spin it round and use it
like an ax thing I'm glad it's not just
the
the obvious
lash out with the with the butt thing
because the sort of Leverage and power
advantage of using this thing as a giant
ax is is what would be the reason for
for having that on there now the problem
with having that on there apart from
potentially cutting and hurting yourself
is what you can see on this example now
this doesn't even have an ax in it and
this two-piece stock design
has fractured quite badly at the wrist
I'm not saying this couldn't stand up to
being used like an ax I'm just saying
that is a weak point in the in any
firearm design clobbering a zombie is
probably a great way to break off your
butt stock at which point this thing
becomes a bit more handy but a lot more
difficult to aim
all right guys those were more guns from
hunt Showdown I know a lot of you have
been requesting more and it was a
pleasure to cover those even better to
have a bit of feedback going both ways
from the developers thank you very much
for your comments there guys and really
nice to see that I'm being of some help
and not just whinging away on a webcam
right if you'd like to visit us at the
armories we have three sites check out
our website of various social media
outlets and our YouTube channel you'll
find deeper dives into some Firearms
there and of course there's also the
loadout series here on Gamespot and with
yours truly as well thanks guys see you
next time
outside
[Music]